I'm calling regards to my Pierre they're
both in their 50s and my dad is ill so
my mom is the only one working at the
time and they have no money saved up for
retirement my mom is she really went
that's bringing in a paycheck you know
she doesn't have a lot extra to put
towards retirement so what would you
suggest would be some aggressive things
you could do to help better prepare them
for retirement well Elise I thank you
for your call I think you know this is
an area that is pushing and weighing in
on a lot of people these days especially
as you have parents that are getting
older and you have kids that you're
trying to launch then they're coming
back and so there's a lot of pressure in
talking about options for your mom what
I would do is sit down and make sure
that we understand exactly what it is
we're dealing with you know what kind of
assets that she had now you don't
mention if she owns her home or not or
if she's renting but I would start to
look at all the assets all the things
that may have been tucked away or put
away investment wise maybe the dad had
an old pension or some things out there
I spend some time doing some research
and bringing it together the realistic
thing you talked about what are things
they can do now I think it's a matter of
getting on a budget if they're not
budgeting I definitely want to encourage
them to do every dollar so they can sit
down until every dollar where to go
instead of wondering where it is but we
got to get serious about this and they
need to as well and I understand with
your father being ill their their hands
are going to be tied on some things that
they can do but I don't want to focus on
what we can't do I want you to stay
focused on what you can do and some
changes can be made but more importantly
you and your husband need to set some
boundaries and understand what are we
going to be able to do here's what
happens when you're in your 50s and
she's not making anywhere near what the
household used to do they have not
adjusted their lifestyle down to her
income and that may mean a move it may
mean some cars that get sold it may mean
some vacations they always have gone on
in quotes but always is over he's ill
and so because saving for retirement
when you're 55 and you have nothing is
just after taking care of food lights
and water I mean if you don't take care
of new your basic necessities today you
don't worry about retirement but before
you start talking about any kind of
lifestyle or any kind of luxury or in
kind of a thing that cost some money you
put you put retirement it becomes very
very very high on the priority list and
that means that some other starts going
to be cut and but not what normally
happens in these situations coaching
them all these years is it is that that
it's just difficult it's kind of like
going through a divorce you know and the
you know the lady ends up with the kids
and some child support and her income is
not was not even fifty percent of the
household income and now they're trying
to live the same lifestyle as prior to
the divorce and because it's the same
math I mean we've lost an income here
that's what we did and that that's what
you're facing so that's what I'd look
into so Chris when people sit down and
look at this number whether they're in a
situation like that or whether it's a
young person sitting and looking at the
number or whether it's a rich person or
poor person whatever they are they sit
down they go to the Chris Hogan 360 calm
they run the are IQ out they figure out
and they get a big number that they need
as their nest egg when they retire and
then it automatically spits out a
monthly number that if you'll save based
on where you are right now what you've
already got saved and what you're going
to add to it if you save this much a
month you'll hit that number that's
right and all of a sudden everything
starts to come clear there's basically
three reactions that happen one of the
three when they see that number yeah the
first one Dave is once they plug that
information is is oh crap and you know
that's that that you see that number you
realize where you are and what you have
left to do so and so it is a man that's
the shock the next one is going to be oh
boy and that's where they're looking at
it they understand that hey they've been
doing some things well they're there
they're there in the vicinity you know
they can see that light at the end of
the tunnel and know that the direction
they're going the final one is oh yeah
these are people that have been invented
you gotta do that with your voice like
oh yeah oh yeah I knew you remember do
that but that's where you start to look
at it you realize you know what we can
see it we're doing it and we're working
the plan and so I talked about that in
the book just because there are three
responses but all three regardless of it
you've got to stay focused you still got
work to do it's always action afterwards
there is whether were they going to deep
hole or whether you're doing good or
whether you're right in the middle
that's right I mean whether the porridge
is just right or it's too
- coal you're right there and you've got
action steps to do on all three category
I sure do for the people that do the riq
and they get oh crap I want you to get
serious immediately I want you to
identify things you can cut back on and
things you can cut back and cut out
you've got to get some more income in
and you've got to get serious you've got
to get serious about budgeting with
every dollar you've got to earn extra
income we've got to get intentional and
if you're the old boy you know you're
doing some things well I want you to
stay focus remember of stay allergic to
debt and make sure you're budgeting
close and finally if you're doing the oh
yeah okay stay motivated stay allergic
to debt remember financial stupid is
everywhere and it's always available and
it feels like the path of least
resistance but it's not there Chris
Hogan 360 dot-com at Chris Hogan 360 or
facebook.com slash Chris Hogan 360 Chris
thanks for hanging out with me this
half-hour thank you for having me Dave
America's voice for retirement and
retirement sanity Chris Hogan this is
the Dave Ramsey show